stéphanie inouïe parts du québec pour
faire de la randonnée en ontario pour la
fin de semaine les alors qu'il marche en
montagne
à la mi temps et se fracture la jambe
ici là qu'ils découvrent qu'ils avaient
oublié un détail important
l'assurance voyage comme il n'était dans
la province voisine que pour la fête
semaine c'est le rôle même pas effleuré
l'esprit
certaines personnes sont couvertes par
une assurance voyage de leur employeur
ce n'était pas le code oui il aurait dû
very vous vous soyez au canada
l'hospitalisation est couverte sauf que
certains services de santé reçu à
l'extérieur du québec de son couvert
qu'en partie ou alors pas du tout le
transport d'urgence marisa la facture de
luiz n'diaye à 920 dollars la régie ne
lui a remboursé que 420 dollars le fin
mot de l'histoire
vous allez dans une autre province
vérifier si vous avez une assurance
voyage parce qu'en cas de malheur
la facture pourrait aussi vous ferme